I grew up in a studio apartment the size of this office at the age that my son is now
I view that I have the advantage over him
Most people don't
I got very lucky. I grew up in a situation where I was losing from day one
We were humble immigrants. I got picked on for not speaking English. I wasn't a good student
I wasn't been excelling athlete which allowed me to create
an enormous amount of thick skin to doing things
and not being scared of judgement, because I was being judged from the beginning
Do you know how obnoxiously thick my skin is when it comes to business. I don't give a f*ck
What anybody says about
Me or thinks of me or thinks what I'm doing
I'm willing to go work picking up garbage right now, right now
It just doesn't seem so crazy to me. People get fucking fancy
I'm still doing the shit that got me here
Even though people think I got somewhere. You may think I got somewhere. I don't think I'm somewhere
I'm still in the same fucking process
And I'm never gonna forget what I'm about and I like getting my hands dirty and I'll answer that email and I'll stop and have that
conversation and I'll take that pitch and I do unscalable. Not the right use of my time shit
50% of my day every day for the rest of my life because I love the fucking dirt. I love the grind
I'll never get fancy. I don't like fancy and so that's important to me. I thank everybody for all those losses
I took along the way. I was picked on heavily, kids forced me to drink pee out of a Pepsi can
I was 4 ft 11. My freshman year of high school
Not good, I was short
I could you know, my home, my infrastructure
The pain and the punishment that that neighborhood put on me as a little fucker that couldn't speak English
I thank you, Dover. And I remind all of you
All your shortcomings and losses and negativity is yesterday
It is all fundamentally behind you
Even the worst of it and it is up to you
to step forward and start positive
offense as your new truth
And I beg that for you and I hope this fucking project suffocated it
and inspired it and created it
and enabled it
And I love you